good morning Leah that's right so good
this year let's see
I applied here I had no idea whether or
not i'd get in I feel like a lot of
people were in similar situation but
when I finally got the phone call saying
I was accepted I thought I was being
pranked and then I started to realize
like wow it's really happening it's just
so surreal morning everyone I'd like to
begin by welcoming you all to MIT into
the chemical engineering department and
to the next two days of your grad
orientation I'd never heard of chemical
engineering fourth so I looked into it
more fell in love with it as a major the
class is all sounded so great and the
job opportunities looks great I feel
like it's a degree that just opens so
many doors it's a great pleasure for me
to look out in this class and see the
future leaders of chemical engineering
and this country and across the world
hoping that we can help you guys to
develop your skills and your confidence
to be able to tackle really difficult
problems it's very intense you'll never
I mean I still to this day remember my
first semester grad school
I got the game yeah we have at the
fridge oh no he's spending a lot of time
here yeah that might not be a bad idea
the biggest thing with this semester is
basically time management and so you'll
find that after the first couple
assignments things will start taking
much longer to accomplish I think a lot
of people at least our your rent into
the fact that like there's a finite
amount of time in a day and you know you
do need to sleep and you do need to eat
and you need to take some time for
yourself to relax do something fun it'll
make doing all this work much more
bearable nice
I do pretty much as soon as I got the
acceptance letter cuz this was my number
one choice when I was applying and I was
really excited about it you can have a
good time here you're still going to get
a great education and that pretty much
sealed the deal for me one of the things
that I noticed is I talked to all the
grad students and they all worked really
hard at all like I work 60 hours to be
fishing thing but none of them seemed
depressed about it they all seemed
really excited about what they're doing
I'm one of those types of people that if
I don't see the application when i'm
doing i can get very disinterested so
I'm fascinated by the fact that what I'm
doing has such far-reaching implications
I've dreamed of coming here since middle
school and I'm finally here